[Music]
if you listen to a lot of the debates
about what's happening in Britain at the
moment you'd think we were living in
some kind of dystopia you know you hear
about the social media and the damage
it's doing to people you hear about
issues like wealth inequality or you
hear about brexit and the potential
Armageddon scenarios you know the plague
of locusts that could emerge and you
could forgiven for thinking that things
are really terrible in Britain and we're
in some kind of state of decline but I
very much disagree with that thesis
about our country in fact I think we're
on the threshold of something that is
very positive and very optimistic and
what I want to talk about today is how
we get there what are the things we need
to do from where we are now to improve
Britain and make our country a brilliant
place to live in and if you look at what
we've achieved with the economy now
after nine difficult years we're now
paying down the debt there's a
proportion of GDP for the first time
we've got Headroom in terms of the
budget brexit is of course a tricky
issue to navigate but the fact is once
we leave the European Union we will have
extra freedom for manoeuvre and I think
one of the most exciting things that's
happening now in Britain is the new
generation that's coming through and I
think this is a different generation
from ones we've seen before I describe
them as heir B and being goober riding
deliverer eating freedom fighters and I
see some people in the audience shaking
their heads but we see opinion polling
shows that younger people are more like
to set up businesses so there's been an
85 percent increase in 18 to 24
year-olds
setting up businesses in the last four
years they're more likely to have a side
hustle alongside the normal work they're
doing whether it's running a YouTube
channel whether it's renting out a
bedroom on
Airbnb whether it's running working in
the economy in different ways and I
think it is because that generation has
grown up with more freedom than previous
generations more information at their
fingertips and more capability and I
don't think it's surprising that that
generation believe in lower taxes then
older people generally do they're also
more interested in things like public
service reform so I think that shows
that there are people out there who want
more opportunities in British society
and I think that over the next few years
we've got the opportunity to get that
energy use their energy and help Britain
become a more successful economy to get
rates of economic growth up but also to
raise the opportunity of every
individual in this country to help them
live their best life so how do we do
that
well first of all the free enterprise
economy is absolutely key to that that
is the thing that gives people the
ability to be able to take control of
their own destiny you don't have freedom
over being able to live your own life if
you can't control your own money and
that's why I think it's so important
that we keep taxes low on people
particularly on those businesses that
are just starting out where people want
to take a risk they want to aspire they
want to do things differently I also
think that we need to make sure the
government is doing less better so I've
been doing a series of spending review
roundtables around the country talking
to people about where they want public
money spent and what people say is they
want money spent on core public services
like the police or education or health
making sure our roads work and I think
that is where we should be focusing our
efforts and too often I mean we have
seen a bit of a creeper creeper plan of
a government where we now have three
hundred and five different quangos and
regulators which cost 2.5 billion
and we've seen more and more regulations
placed on people's everyday lives and
businesses so is it really the business
of government to be saying to people how
big their pizza should be or what the
minimum price of a glass of wine should
be I would rather the government is
focusing on those core basics they're
going to help people get on in life and
if the ultimate devolution of power is
to the individual which I believe I
believe firmly that we need to empower
people and as people become more capable
more informed they're better placed to
take decisions than the government are
but as that happens I also think we need
to devolve more power to local
authorities Britain is than one of the
most centralized countries in the
Western world and of course part of that
decentralization is brexit that will
enable us to make more decisions here in
Britain but I don't think people will be
satisfied by voting for brexit if they
don't see more of those powers going to
their local areas rather than those
decisions being made in Whitehall one of
the things I think we should be looking
at is can we devolve more taxes there's
a very good paper out recently by the
Institute of Fiscal Studies talking
about devolving 3 pence of basic rate
income tax to be spent at a local level
and I think that would be a good thing
for various reasons first of all it
would mean that those low called bits of
local government have an incentive to
help the economy grow attract people to
the area
help people earn more money it also
provides a sustainable form of finance
for local government rather than what we
have at the moment which is very much
based on a central government grant
system and it would mean that decisions
over issues like transport could be made
by local areas about what they see as
the priority and now I am concerned
about the fact that at the moment cities
like Leeds cities like Birmingham don't
have the type of transport that they
deserve
Leeds is the biggest city in you
without it saying mass transit network
and that has been a failure of
successive governments to build that
type of infrastructure but I think the
really the way we're really going to
shift the dial on that is by actually
allowing leads and other cities and
other counties across the country to
keep more of the revenue raised there so
they can spend it on improving local
infrastructure so I think that's
something we need to do as a country we
need to make sure that more money is
both raised and spent locally to be able
to improve the local situation and I
think in doing that we need to recognize
that this concept of the postcode
lottery which often dominates British
politics we've got to be careful of
talking about that all the time because
I want different parts of Britain
different parts of England to be able to
do things differently and to be able to
have different priorities it's one of
the reasons we put in place the police
and crime commissioners say that local
priorities could be reflected and I
think we need to allow that more in our
public services so we shouldn't just
have diversity of individuals making
their own decisions about their own
lives we should also allow more
diversity in terms of the way towns
provide services in terms of the way
cities provide services in terms of the
way those decisions are made but having
said that I think there is an absolute
need to make sure that everybody in this
country has the universal basic
infrastructure to succeed now I'm not a
fan of universal basic income I think it
is a proposal that would end up paying
large amounts of money to people who are
already very well-off and the evidence
in countries like Finland is that it
hasn't worked but I do think we have an
issue of unfairness in our society which
is that some parts the country will see
fiber-to-the-home
or better broadband delivered 10 years
later than other people I don't think
that's right and I don't think it's fair
and if we are to have a successful free
enterprise economy we need to make sure
that everybody can't participate in it
we need to make sure that every child is
able to get up to a basic level of
education to have English and maths we
need to make sure that every household
is able to access the Internet and has
that fiber to their premises we need to
focus when we're thinking about
transport infrastructure on people's
journeys to work because it isn't fair
that it costs so much more to get to
work in some parts of the country than
others and in some parts of the country
this simply isn't the transport
available so I think the concept of
universal basic infrastructure is really
important otherwise people feel that
they are cut off from the opportunities
that a successful free enterprise
economy provides so these are some of
the areas that I think we should focus
on but finally we also need to recognize
the world has changed since know since
the paternalistic companies of the 1950s
I remember when I first started at work
I I work for Shell and they still had a
company dentist they they had a company
bar you know everything was provided by
the company and that's what it used to
be like for motivates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas her III TV
you